uh explain to me like uh what was the
moment like when you first get out where
you decided to go like ten toes in on
this rap [ __ ] because I'm assuming like
I was on a roof getting paid 80 a day
about to fall off that [ __ ] every time
like doing manual labor not knowing what
I was doing nothing unskilled doing my
construction I'm coming and I'm coming
out of jail and everyone's like you
better go out there and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up like cause I'm
you know I hit home and the people like
I said I've said this before like people
weren't as quick to want to help you
because they're like what are you doing
you're trying to rap dude like damn come
on man get a [ __ ] job you just got
out here go back to jail man yeah people
who care about you yep
and you gotta decide like right there
like all right what am I doing it's
balls to the wall
boss to the walls gotta believe just go
believe in yourself and then you know
when you start knocking down doors you'd
be like oh yeah I'm a [ __ ] door
knocker down there you know what I'm
saying you're more than one way knocking
on those doors man